[Música]
hola bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de
reporteros aquí en france24 hoy por mi
compañera ángela gutiérrez en las
elecciones presidenciales de eeuu el
voto en ciertos estados es predecible
pero en otros conocidos como los estados
pendulares puede haber sorpresas
nuestros periodistas viajaron a los
estados clave de minnesota y wisconsin
para ver si los votantes en el corazón
de eeuu van a elegir a una lección o joe
biden como su próximo presidente en las
elecciones del 3 de noviembre hablamos
con una de las realizadoras de este
reportaje jessica leí me subí a jessica
la saludó quiénes son los votantes que
usted cree que tendrán el mayor impacto
en estos estados pendulares
y en este documental decidimos
concentrarnos en los votantes cuyos
votos serán los más importantes en estos
estados pendulares fuimos a minnesota y
fuimos a minneapolis y hablamos con
votantes afroamericanos muchos de ellos
se abstuvieron en la pasada elección y
eso tuvo un impacto y por eso minnesota
casi cayó en manos de los republicanos
también hablamos con menores que
históricamente han votado demócrata pero
en la última elección muchos votaron por
thom y fuimos a averiguar si planean
hacer lo mismo otra vez y luego fuimos a
wisconsin en un estado donde chong ganó
sorpresivamente en la última elecciones
sobre todo gracias al voto rural pero
desde entonces ha habido una guerra
comercial con china y eso es algo que
realmente ha impactado a los campesinos
y por eso fuimos a ver si volverán a
votar por trump anda el empate de dos
fusiones
holmes en descanso y ser winterfield
estamos still be bad things we stand
with explica bloggers también fuimos a
hablar con leñadores en wisconsin porque
trump
ha tratado con mucha fuerza de atraerlos
y descubrimos como verán en las primeras
imágenes del documental lo que es
importante para ellos realmente atesoran
su segunda enmienda el derecho a tener y
portar armas los invitamos entonces a
ver el siguiente reportaje
[Música]
si quieren una guerra civil eso es
exactamente lo que hay que hacer
es decir que nos van a quitar nuestras
armas creo que joe biden dijo que sólo
se necesita una escopeta
yo quiero más que una escopeta
aguardan
yo creo que está sorprendido de ver que
hay granjeros en este país él no siente
no nos ve la única razón por la cual
sabe que existimos que porque los
granjeros votan por él la gran mayoría
de las personas con las que trabajo en
los que trabajan en otras minas una gran
mayoría está a favor de trump él
respalda a la clase obrera aunque sea
millonario nuestros padres nuestros
abuelos eran todos demócratas entonces
es difícil ver a todas esas personas del
norte de minnesota unirse al presidente
de donald trump me arrepentí de haber
votado por trompa el día de su posición
cuando mintió sobre la cantidad de
personas que estaban presentes
estoy muy contenta por salir a votar y
no solo tengo el derecho de votar es
también un placer y un privilegio
se llaman juniors jon lovitz y rossini
viven y votan en los estados de
wisconsin y minnesota dos estados
pendulares dos estados clave que pueden
cambiar el rostro de eeuu en 2016 las
promesas de donald trump sedujeron a los
electores wisconsin se inclinó del lado
republicano por primera vez en 36 años
minnesota se mantuvo demócrata por unos
cuantos miles de votos un estado donde
el presidente saliente multiplicó los
desplazamientos en particular en la
cuenca minera
[Música]
conductor de máquinas desde hace 25 años
es un minero orgulloso de sus orígenes
hace cuatro años square dio al atún al
sur una revelación hace años toda esta
región era demócrata y de hecho yo
también votaba por los demócratas dicen
que respaldan a los trabajadores pero
mantienen todos sus programas radicales
a favor del medio ambiente nos van a
quitar nuestro trabajo
[Música]
yo yo
me gusta que donald trump no sea un
político es un hombre de negocios era
hora de que eso cambiara un poco en este
país fuimos a una reunión de trampa el
miércoles pasado fue una de las
experiencias más increíbles de mi vida
nunca me habría imaginado poder ver en
persona a un presidente estadounidense y
mucho menos a uno que admiro y fue el
momento más hermoso de la vida de mi
hijo
son wifi
a unos kilómetros de ahí hablé antigua
capital minera convertida en una ciudad
fantasma los almacenes están vacíos y
las calles desiertas con una competencia
internacional en aumento las minas que
representaban la fuerza de la región
cierran una detrás de otra
jon el gas es un líder sindical enfrenta
cada vez más decepciones de parte de los
obreros como junio
cómo puede alguien escoger a donald
trump después de todos sus ataques a
nuestro estilo de vida en estos últimos
tres años no lo entiendo es amigo de
grandes empresas que le pertenecen a sus
amigos ricos nosotros obreros y obreras
no le importamos eso es seguro no hizo
nada por nosotros por aquí no estamos
viendo delante de nosotros he pinchado
una de las últimas minas de hierro
activas en minnesota es uno de los
últimos trabajos que nos quedan aquí en
la cuenca minera entonces qué será de
nosotros es decir no podemos trabajar en
turismo por ejemplo y criar a una
familia de cuatro recibiendo un salario
de ocho dólares la hora es duro cuando
tienes hijos pequeños y cuando debes
encontrar una manera de alimentarlos
vestir los enviarlos a la universidad
mientras la mina está cerrada es muy
doloroso
donald trump no sólo sedujo a la clase
obrera en los bosques de wisconsin de
ver mi miller un leñador de 41 años
trabaja de sol a sol para alimentar a su
familia y pagar sus préstamos
[Música]
y no es un trabajo fácil no hay que
amarlo de verdad porque si no es posible
ganar mucho más dinero haciendo un
trabajo más fácil pero es tan tranquilo
aquí tan hermoso realmente el valor
enagás de camps donde a ellos y ellos
mover
al igual que muchos habitantes de las
zonas rurales jeremy miller busca sobre
todo limitar la intervención del estado
federal
en realidad no quiero nada no quiero
calidad ni seguridad social gratuita
simplemente quiero que me dejen vivir mi
vida
my own way
según el donald trump es la opción
correcta para proteger su oficio que
considera amenazado
los demócratas tienen tendencia a ser
más restrictivos hay varias cosas que
nos molestan por ejemplo que pongan
animales en listas de especies
amenazadas como la lechuza por ejemplo o
cualquier otra especie creo que podemos
protegerlos sin poner tantas
restricciones estrictas porque si no no
podremos seguir haciendo nuestro trabajo
como leñadores
rico en bosques wisconsin es también la
lechería de eeuu el estado tiene el
récord de la mayor cantidad de granjas
lecheras en el país
lynn y que tampoco cuenta sus horas de
trabajo sacar los animales limpiar el
establo administrar los pedidos con su
esposo dirige una granja familiar de 75
reses y hasta los niños contribuyen con
su parte hace un año la granja hicks se
declaró en bancarrota y hoy vende bien
en parte a causa de la guerra aduanera
con beijing llevada a cabo por la
administración las exportaciones hacia
china cayeron en picado el precio de la
leche se redujo a la mitad se derramaron
muchas lágrimas porque para mí era como
si hubiese fracasado sin embargo los
geeks se resisten en condenar al
presidente y pienso que a largo plazo si
él está ahí por un nuevo mandato nos
daremos cuenta de que lo que empezó a
hacer era algo bueno
en wisconsin la mayor parte de los
agricultores apoyó ante donald trump no
es el caso de los rose home john es la
quinta generación de la granja familiar
él y su mujer perdieron 400.000 dólares
con la crisis de la leche desde entonces
están inundados por ayudas de parte de
washington
es bastante gracioso porque los
republicanos no dejan de decir que están
en contra del socialismo en contra del
comunismo que no quieren que el gobierno
intervenga
pero cada vez que hay un presidente
republicano recibimos ayudas se envían
dinero y ninguno de nosotros sabe cómo
reembolsar esa suma es realmente irónico
voten el 3 de noviembre voten baiden
jarvis
en la casa de el rosón home se exhibe su
preferencia
como la hacemos entender a las personas
que no deben tener miedo de colgar sus
pancartas es una locura
me pone mal vengan y miren mi casa tengo
pancartas escuché a mujeres que viven en
el norte de wisconsin se cuentan que
tiene miedo de sacarlas porque sus
vecinos tienen fusiles semiautomáticos
pero en fin estamos en eeuu
así es como logro escaparme
[Música]
tiene un gato
oscar
minneapolis capital de minnesota lejos
de las preocupaciones de las campañas la
prioridad aquí es realizarse la prueba
el coronavirus ha afectado en particular
a la comunidad afroamericana
aquí hoy se pueden inscribir para votar
y para hacerse la prueba del virus
una prueba y la posibilidad de
inscribirse para votar hace cuatro años
los votantes afroamericanos urbanos y
tradicionalmente demócratas no se
movilizaron fue aquí donde el pasado
mayo georges fue fue asesinado por la
policía este monumento recuerda el
nombre de una centena de afroamericanos
víctimas del racismo de las fuerzas del
orden
para la pastora bautista reseña poder
votar es hacer justicia en este
cementerio justo detrás mío ya sin
simbólicamente george lloyd y brión a
taylor y ellos ya no pueden votar
entonces nosotros debemos ser su voz
debemos el su voto para decir basta
luchamos por nuestra vida misma en esta
elección tenemos un presidente que
promueve la supremacía blanca entonces
nuestro voto cuenta ahora más que nunca
sé que algunos de nosotros están muy
tristes algunos de nosotros han
renunciado pero no es el momento de
abandonar las manifestaciones a veces
violentas de minneapolis y en las
grandes ciudades de eeuu después de la
muerte de georg project asustaron a los
habitantes de las zonas rurales como el
leñador germi miller y su amigo james
hay una razón por la cual no veremos
nunca manifestaciones como las de
minneapolis en una pequeña ciudad como
ésta porque
porque todo el mundo aquí tiene un arma
si alguien trata de entrar a una casa o
está buscando problemas esa persona
simplemente será recibida con unos tiros
muchas personas están listas estamos
listos para la guerra si yo voy de ganar
es porque alguien hizo trampas
el temor de lo desconocido del
extranjero lowry mca me lo conoce muy
bien en 2016 esta abuela de 65 años
vivía en california asustada por la
inmigración clandestina foto por trump
trump nos hizo creer que méxico iba a
pagar para construir un muro en la
frontera y esa es la única razón por la
cual vote por él debo admitir que no me
sentí muy bien y que me arrepentí muy
rápido cuando vi a los niños encerrados
en jaulas soy madre y soy abuela a mamá
era mi crema
quitarles los niños a los padres samad
sword
algunos de ellos todavía recibían leche
materna cuando fueron separados de sus
madres al médico y algunos no podrán
jamás volver a encontrar a sus padres
porque no se sabe dónde están
eso va más allá de la crueldad es pérez
bianco
flor y hace parte de un movimiento que
surgió a principios de la campaña
presidencial los republicanos
contrataron al trump un grupo
desilusionado por la política del
presidente y que prefiere apoyar a
campaña en minneapolis rozín ya dejó su
papeleta en la urna por anticipado al
igual que un tercio de los electores de
minnesota
[Música]
mi nombre
conmigo
y en este estado clave cada voto es
importante
sigue con nosotros nuestra reportera
jessica le mensaje a jessica gracias por
este reportaje que acabamos de ver y que
importar a las personas en el corazón de
eeuu
en general la gente sólo quiere poder
alimentar a sus hijos poder apoyar a sus
familias tener buenos empleos y trabajar
duro muchos nos hablaron de lo fuerte
que trabajan cada semana especialmente
los campesinos y los mineros los
leñadores y también ser libres su
libertad personal es muy importante para
ellos y para ellos el socialismo es una
palabra sucia es lo que vimos es que
están divididos al país y es algo muy
aparente en estos dos estados hubo un
momento cuando estábamos caminando por
la frontera entre estos dos estados a lo
largo del río mississippi con lori y uno
de sus amigos
franks acá estuvo allí con ella ella es
una republicana que ha abandonado a
trump ahora se siente asqueada por él y
su amigo quiere votar por trump y nos
dice que incluso dentro de su propia
familia las divisiones que estamos
viendo en este país son muy profundas
ahora tiene alguna idea de quién ganará
en estos o dos estados
todas las encuestas sugieren que bailen
ganará pero eso no es necesariamente la
impresión que nos dejó el terreno
trump aún tiene mucho apoyo y parece que
la gente todavía lo quiere no hay nada
que él pueda hacer que lo dejaría votar
en su contra eso fue algo muy
interesante pero dependerá mucho de si
los afro-americanos salen a votar y
parece que sí lo harán
muchos como nuestro personaje resin ya
ya votaron de manera anticipada en esta
elección
jessica gracias por este reportaje y
gracias a ustedes también por
acompañarnos aquí esta emisión de
reporteros en france 24
[Música]